welcome to this video playing baritone
from Finland his um this is five minute
this is five minute I actually intended
to play a 15 minute game it's good that
I see it now I was thinking okay so
relatively high rated and then I thought
wow I'm I'm really high rated for 15
minutes what happened the thing is it's
not 15 minutes five minutes so just a
regular five minute game and we have by
transposition reached a position from
the symmetrical English age 6 not even
threatening something hmm yeah maybe
maybe play a developing move each sixes
really hit its kind of nothing yeah okay
I want to get rid of the pin this I
cannot really object against it's a oh
really this looks weakening to me and
this weakening the dark squares
considerably I just not care still
before hangs I mean if it if he plays
rugby wanna take ya now he just has the
weak porn here
now the question is how bad is the deck
okay i can go Bishop c5 it's it's really
a strong PCM and then here so what is he
doing ok I take at the end i can go ok
too but it's not helping much why can
play Bishop c6 ok mother's I can do
anyway can always play Bishop Bishop c6
and then take but this is opposite
colored bishops it's not not really
brilliant ok I gained some skin some
more space so that after night d4f I
have ff4 maybe I can get an age form if
he takes just look a jade and switching
ok I don't want that I don't really
understand the point you're going to try
to double here i cain't the edge file
intending rook age too okay if I go
check here yeah I can I can better I can
better attack ear attack the weakness
now okay if I take now and play Bishop
to e4 yeah I take pressure before he
probably will I know he really cannot he
cannot I thought he might second
exchange but it's not possible really he
can second exchange but I take it three
at the end just like here I take III
okay so let's see not allowing
counterplay would be nice iam I have it
everything everything is nicely
protected this is a very good Bishop I I
must get the rock over it's not doing
much on a five of course I never want to
take on a three give up this monster
Bishop just Rock h8 and invasion is much
better I have the GNC for porn that I
can win
yeah okay I could take now I mean yeah
it's just it's just stupid it is stupid
to give up this Bishop such a strong
piece I can bet I really better just to
to try to invade and then see how to how
to win let's let's consider ya hear keep
everything attacked and now maybe of six
f6 and d5
hmm yeah it's not not winning so easily
check
neither thinks got 9 p-2 fiver this is
not good I've been I've been bit slow
here check check check check 35 seconds
yeah the bishop is protecting all pawns
absolutely all pawns so it's still
relatively easy win but 28 seconds
check ya then it's a promotion now check
time warning check mate yeah this was a
very nice position right out of the
opening it's uh well it's the bishop and
a good center that I got yeah this is
just very nice and before hmm before is
helping black enormously before that I'd
say it's um nothing special but before
nope and f3 weakens the dark square I
mean now Black is just just better maybe
you should play b5 I don't know it's
it's it's both not great TM yeah here
black is just in a position ray can play
for win risk-free I can probably save
time by not playing look to a age and
push what I did here without moving the
rook in the first place otay this is
completely toast the only thing is I
just played it very badly from a
technical point of view I hear work g3
is stronger yeah I wanted to get this
back into play but this is stronger as
rookie fries signing into this one
winning the Jeep on but ok this is also
total win
it only took me took me a bit long yeah
yeah 22 to win it at the end alright
thanks for watching